i told you last week that after joe
biden's absolutely
brutal speech
about the january 6th riots on the
one-year anniversary going right after
donald trump for his role in inciting
those riots
trump was so triggered trump put out
four consecutive statements bizarre
grammar random capitalization each
statement basically just a repetition of
the previous really really strange stuff
well after that donald trump was
interviewed by oan
oan is the even more radical right-wing
network to newsmax which is already a
more radical right-wing version of fox
news which is crazy so imagine where
newsmax is newsmax went down to florida
it's relevant that this took place in
florida and you'll see why in a moment
and donald trump just can't even string
together a single coherent argument i
mean this is arguably the easiest
interview in history the interviewer was
getting autographs from trump either
before or after the interview she was
pictured this is like a fan of trump's
just letting him do whatever he wants
and it's still humiliating and trump is
still saying
any second now states are going to be
turned over to him
he's talking about the 2020 election i i
know you're saying it's david sir it's
2022.
trump is talking about flipping states
in the 2020 election we ran a third
world election
and things are coming out over the next
couple of days maybe even today we're
always days away from the blockbuster
one case i hear a very big story is
coming out today
on the cheating
and
numerous states are going to be
turned i don't know what they're going
to do but it's going to show that they
were won by me it's already shown right
if you look at if you look at arizona if
you look at the findings in arizona is
it sad at this point guys
that it's still the same talking points
that's over right we want it
and i'm gonna go out there next week
we're making a speech but if you look at
those findings
we won the state so trump did not win
arizona now then
trump goes back to talking about the
size of his pathetic
crowd
he again is talking about crowd size i i
know it's 20 22. everything was going
beautifully and then the election got
rigged
and stolen
from the american people and by the way
that's the reason they went in
massive numbers they don't cover the
numbers of people they always show the
capital with a very small just a tiny
percentage of the people that were there
they never show helicopter
pictures of that incredible crowd
because it was the largest crowd i've
ever spoken before
i i believe he's talking about the
january 6th crowd never had a crowd i've
never seen a crowd that big
he's never even read oh right he doesn't
read so okay then it was massive it was
the real number i won't say imagine the
interview it was it was massive it was
massive because it'll be a headline oh
he exaggerated the number the real
number
was over that sacred number okay you
know what that number was right i do and
sacred uh i i don't even talk about that
it's kind of talking about it right now
then trump very strangely started saying
the media is censoring pictures of how
big the crowd was i mean this is a very
sick individual but why do we have such
a dishonest press that's a question and
why don't they show the real crowd right
that was there on january 6th the crowd
of people that was the biggest i've ever
seen i haven't seen anybody you can
hardly get a picture
we're trying to find pictures
they have they have censored to pick the
pictures
they don't want to show that crowd it's
all been completely it's you you can't
go to google images and type in trump
january 6
oh you can oh oh you get thousands of
results oh sorry
the pictures are censored now one nice
moment
nice
is when trump continues to go after
mitch mcconnell and mike pence for the
election loss this is really great news
because it shows us the continued divide
within the party which is what the left
has the left is doing so poorly at
putting together a good strategy for 22
we have to hope that their own division
will hurt them trump going right after
mcconnell and pence here take a look
what do you think uh
what does the american public need to do
in order to
not just feel secure but actually secure
our elections well we have to get better
people than mitch mcconnell who
immediately gave up
and you know mike pence was it was sad
because when you have more votes and you
have voters you could send that back
to the legislatures right right send it
back hey excuse me we have more votes
and runs would you check it out
and by that time they would have done
something because as you know they were
starting to get angry around that time
they said wait a minute we've been
scammed they're a protester so that was
disappointing with mike and mitch
mcconnell
shouldn't have accepted it isn't that
the best how
it is not common that a president so
consistently
criticizes his own vice president and
said mike failed us it was really
disappointing mike pence couldn't have
done anything and mike pence was right
he knew it
then the topic came up of what actually
happened on january 6th and trump talked
about
uh all of the love
that day take a look at this this is
wild and it was cold that day people
people were very cold and weren't it was
love that day there was so much love out
there during the speech
but a tiny percentage and they started
walking to the capitol
in many cases before i even spoke right
it couldn't it it was their idea it
wasn't even anything trump did you know
that was well known yeah but um
they should show helicopter shots right
of the crowd not taken six hours before
like they did with my inauguration
you know were they still talking about
the crowd size
in 2017 guys you know the inauguration
hours before
and they talk about oh not that many
people because i tell you what it went
down to the washington monument and they
know it
just like they showed the empty
basketball arena
and they said basketball the guy is
still talking about the crowd size now
the interview is completely unhinged
what we're expecting at the rally in
arizona on saturday is probably more of
this this is a very very sick man but
one of the really funny things is when
trump was president the faa wouldn't
allow planes to fly over mar-a-lago you
know mar-a-lago down in florida there
it's near so many different airports and
the flight paths that's not happening
anymore and multiple times i just love
this multiple times during the interview
you hear planes right overhead and you
can see you can see and hear in trump's
voice that he gets annoyed by it it is
constant now check this out but people
respected us and they weren't going to
mess around you know when you're weak
you end up in wars
and
we were respected so one year ago
we were respected like probably never
before one year ago we were respected
now he can't even get the planes to stop
flying over mar-a-lago it happens again
later in the interview and again it just
sort of seems to slightly distract trump
you know his ego is very bruised that
now planes are making noise over his
house all day you do and what oan does
is so important
and you have a much bigger audience than
people understand thank you but you
cover it better than anybody and
we're talking about elections that are
broken rigged
and you've been saying this you were
saying this all right so you guys get it
just just another one of these insane
interviews and uh
do not be confused
this will continue trump will continue
uh meddling in or you know metal
depending on your perspective meddling
or being involved in uh republican
politics
until the republican party doesn't allow
him anymore
or until his health goes bad and he's
not able to anymore but he seems as
determined as ever to be involved so a
humiliating oan interview there's going
to be more of this coming make sure
you're following us on instagram at
david pakman show
one of our sponsors is self-decode
self-decode is a genetic testing and
analysis platform that gives you tools
to gain insights about your health based
on your dna this is a new technology
we're still learning so much about
what of substantive value can we get
from these types of results but by using
artificial intelligence and machine
learning you can get personalized
insights based on your specific dna as
well as getting lab test analysis and
recommendations really a lot of
interesting ways to get information
about yourself through the self-decode
platform they never sell your
information they never give away your
information to anybody self-decode sent
me a dna kit to get my saliva i did the
test sent it back and in just a few
weeks i had my results i found for
example that genetically i'm not at big
risk for kidney stones
not at big risk for asthma
unfortunately i'm at slightly increased
risk of headaches which is true which is
true and the recommendations you get are
really simple and logical things
relating to sleep relaxation etc very
very interesting and this is a
technology that's going to develop and
mature significantly over the next five
to ten years self-decode is giving my
audience 25 off when you click the link
below and use the coupon code pacman